je ne pense pas et vous ne me ferez pas
dire que tous les immigrés notamment
ceux qui essayent manière tragique de
traverser la méditerranée pour rejoindre
un avenir meilleur pense-t-il sont des
terroristes en puissance ou du
délinquant puissant je ne le pense pas
mais il ya des liens ils ont été
démontrés par les enquêtes du procureur
de reims ils ont été démontrés par un de
vos confrères journalistes de médiapart
dans un livre il y a des liens entre les
réseaux terroristes qui utilisent les
flux migratoires et qui les un filtre ça
c'est clair
moi je pense que puisque nous sommes sur
un sujet différent mais qui a des liens
qu'il faut décider dans ce pays un
moratoire en matière d'immigration
un moratoire il faut prendre le temps de
vérifier d'évaluer le cas des champs de
changer les procédures des pratiques de
faire le point lardon par an pendant
cinq ans ce que vous dites mais jamais
parce que l'immigration est ce que ça
veut dire immigration zéro parce qu'on a
quand même des étudiants qui rendent
dans ce pays est ce que ça veut dire
comment donner on ferme complètement les
frontières on se pose on fait un état
des lieux où on continue à voir et bien
des étudiants qui viennent étudier en
france de l'étrange évidemment on va
toujours accueillir des étudiants c'est
une des forces toujours des réfugiés
également des universités françaises que
de cuir beaucoup d'étudiants il faut
même en accueillir davantage sont de
vrais étudiants il ya toujours la
question des réfugiés du droit d'asile
que nous devons ré dossier oppose part
je trouve qu'il ya sur ce sujet du
climat de l'environnement qui est un de
mes combats depuis longtemps je suis à
droite un de ceux qui s'est intéressée
depuis très longtemps à vous allez
dénigrement et j'ai écrit plusieurs
livres sur ces sujets il ya une forme de
deux de précipitation de fébrilité ou
d'incertitude je ne vois pas la ligne
comme d'ailleurs dans d'autres domaines
je trouve qu'il y a dans la manière de
gouverner actuellement d'un ancien
référendum sans en mesurer les
conséquences apercevoir qu il pose des
problèmes ne pas écouter le sait